I thought it was particularly
interesting in the documentaries a
couple of thoughts I had about the
documentary there was some comment made
by you about your critics will say you
write music for white people and I'm
sitting there going you just got to
write the music that's in your head you
don't know who's going to respond to it
you don't know if black people white
people you don't know who is gonna it's
an unfair criticism and it only goes
towards stifling whatever you have
inside of you I mean that it's a hurtful
thing to hear that right
very hurtful
um only because like I am a black woman
and I feel like it really like
challenges like my identity and who I am
and diminishes that which I think is
really hurtful and then on the other end
it's like I'm making funky Soulful feel
good music that is so similar to a lot
of black music that was made for black
people in the 70s and 80s and you know
and then on top of that my message is
literally for everybody and anybody and
I don't I don't you know
um try to gatekeep my message from
people so all three of those things for
me I'm just like you don't even get me
at all and I feel like a lot of people
truthfully don't get me which is why I
wanted to do this documentary because I
was like I feel like y'all don't
understand me y'all don't know where I
came from and now I don't want to answer
no more questions about this [ __ ] I want
to show the world like who I am